deux journées où anthony blinken a passé
de nombreux de longues heures à parler
avec la ministre des affaires étrangères
allemande anna-lena bareback ainsi
qu'avec les ministres aussi français le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian ont montré
qu'en fait les liens transatlantiques se
resserrait et puis c'est vrai que cette
relation entre l'allemagne et les états
unis elle avait été lourdement éprouvée
lors des années trump aux états unis et
là on voit un resserrement de ses liens
avec à la fois anna lena bareback qui a
été très familière avec un tony blinken
elle a appelé chair tony elle a tutoyé
tout au long de la conférence de presse
elle a précisé que c'était une relation
amicale une relation de partenariat un
partenariat qu'a également souligné
anthony blinken anthony blinken qui a
remercié l'allemagne
2-2 ce partenariat il a aussi tenu à
remercier la france on veut vraiment que
c'est une nouvelle ère qui s'ouvre entre
entre les états unis et l'allemagne et
l'europe et puis on voit aussi un
changement à berlin un changement de ton
aussi avec washington mais pas seulement
aussi un changement ton vis-à-vis de la
russie et dans la relation avec la
russie justement y at il des dissensions
au sein du gouvernement allemand
emmanuel
oui tout à fait il y as est vrai qu on
avait vu lors du gouvernement merkel
plus la politique était plutôt à
l'apaisement des tensions
angela merkel qui avait été l'une des
architectes du projet de gazoduc nord
stream 2 notamment elie tenais je tenais
à cette diplomatie économique et bien
c'est pas le cas d'anna lena haberbusch
qui entraîne certaines frictions
d'ailleurs au gouvernement même si ces
dissensions sont pas publics mais on
sait que la schl le chancelier
social-démocrate à lui toujours soutenu
ce projet de gazoduc pour maintenir
notamment les relations économiques avec
la russie donc on peut s'imaginer que
kylie à des tensions entre le chancelier
et la ministre des affaires étrangères
à voir si cette nouvelle politique
étrangère initié par anna-lena berlocq
continuera à faire long feu ici à berlin